翻訳: Hiroyuki Sugiura
校正: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
我々人間は 昔から
宇宙まで自由に行きたいというですね
そういう願望を持っていました
昔は 宇宙というよりは
天空と言った方がいいかも
しれませんけれども
古くからある「バベルの塔」とか
「ジャックと豆の木」ですね
みなさんご存知の
それも天まで届くお話ですよね
科学技術の発展した現在
我々は ロケットによって宇宙まで
行くことができるようになりました
しかしながら その宇宙まで行けるのは
ほんのわずかの人たちです
限られた人たちだけです
それがもしですね 一般の人たちも
安く 宇宙に行くことが
できるようになったとすれば
そういう時代が 近いー
将来 訪れるとすればですね
今日は そういう方法について
皆さんに紹介したいと思います
その方法というのは「宇宙エレベーター」と
呼ばれるものなんですね
じゃあ 宇宙エレベーターって
どういうものでしょうか
こういうものです
どうでしょう
皆さんが想像していたものとは
少し違うかもしれないですね
エレベーターと言うと タワーが立っていて
そこを箱が昇っていく
そういうイメージかと思いますけれども
さすがに宇宙まで タワーを立てる
というのは不可能ですので
宇宙エレベーターの場合は
軌道にあるステーションから
ケーブルを伸ばしてきて 地上と付ける
そのケーブルに沿って「クライマ」
と呼ばれる昇降機で昇り降りする
そういったものになります
この昇降機については いろんな方法が
考えられているんですけれども
今 主に検討されているのは
ケーブルに車輪を噛まして昇って行く
そういう方法です
このクライマ自体は
だいたい新幹線一両分ぐらいの大きさで
そのスピードも新幹線ぐらい
だいたい時速2、300キロぐらいですかね
それぐらいのものが 現在考えられています
では この宇宙エレベーターの構成について
もう少し詳しく見てみましょう
ケーブルですけれども
ケーブルは 静止軌道と呼ばれる所にある
「ステーション」と地上を結ぶ
これが基本になります
静止軌道というのは
赤道面上高度3万6000キロの軌道で
放送衛星なんかが飛んでる軌道です
その静止軌道というのは
地球の自転と合った形で周っているので
地上から見ると
常に静止しているように見えます
従って そこと結んでも
ずれるということはないんですね
ただし これだけですと
全体として引力の方が強いので
このステーションが落ちてきてしまいます
それを落ちてこないようにするためには
このステーションの外側に
「アンカー」重りですね
重りを付けてやって
遠心力で引っ張り上げてやる
そういうことが 必要になります
そのために ケーブル全体としては
10万キロぐらいの非常に長いものになります
10万キロというと
これは月までの距離のおよそ４分の１
とっても長いですよね
これだけ長いケーブルですと
今までの材料ですと
自分の重さで切れてしまいます
従って「宇宙エレベーターって不可能だね」
というふうに思われていたんですけれども
ところがですね
25年前
日本で「カーボンナノチューブ」という
新しい材料が発明されました
カーボンナノチューブというのは
炭素が非常に強い力で結びついていて
それがチューブ状になっているものです
そのチューブの直径は
数から数十ナノメーター
１ナノメーターというのは
百万分の１ミリのことなんですけれども
このカーボンナノチューブというのは
アルミニウムの半分ぐらいの重さで
その強さは 鋼鉄の100倍以上の
強さを持っています
こういう軽くて強い材料で
宇宙エレベーターのケーブルが作れれば
10万キロという長さでも
切れることはありません
こういった新しい材料の発明とか
それから科学技術の発展もあってですね
20年ぐらい前から
「宇宙エレベーターって できそうだねぇ」
という機運が高まってきました
じゃあ この宇宙エレベーターができたら
いったい何が良いのか
ということなんですけども
そもそも 今使えているロケットというのは
一度荷物を運んだらそれでお終いです
使い捨てなんですよね
ところが宇宙エレベーターというのは
一旦これを完成させれば
ケーブルに沿って何度でも
荷物を輸送することができます
従って１回あたりの輸送コストが
非常に安くなる
だいたい化学ロケット
今までのロケットの百分の１ぐらいになる
という風に言われてます
百分の１ぐらいになるというのは
どれくらいかというと
例えば 低い軌道まで人が一人行くのに
百万円ぐらいで行ける
ということになっています
百万円というと まぁ 少し豪華な
海外旅行という感じですかね
一般の人でも手の届く金額かと思います
このように コストが安くなりますと
宇宙に新しい工場を作ったり
病院を作ったりして
そこで宇宙環境を利用した
新しい製品を作ったり
新しい治療をしたり 更には
娯楽施設を作ったり
ホテルを作ったりしても
十分採算が取れるようになるんですね
従っていろんな分野で
非常に広がりができる
ということになっていきます
では 宇宙エレベーターを作るには
どれくらいのコストが掛かるか？ですけれども
これはNASAとか大手建設会社の
見積もりによりますと
建造期間が だいたい10から20年ぐらい
そして 開発費は数兆円から10兆円ぐらい
という風に見積もられています
現在 建設が進んでいる新東名
これを見てみましょう
新東名は 全線開通に
建設期間がだいたい25年
そして総工費が７兆円ぐらい
というふうに言われていますから
この宇宙エレベーター１台作るというのは
これは新しい道路を１つ作るぐらい
だということが言えるのですね
ということで 天文学的数字じゃない
ということになります
こういう宇宙エレベーターですけれども
もちろん その本格的な研究が始まってですね
まだ20年ぐらいしか経っていません
20年も経ってないですね
従って 先ほどのカーボンナノチューブが
発明されたとはいえ
その強さを保ちながらケーブルにする
という技術はまだありません
他にも克服すべき
技術的課題は沢山あります
そういう状況なんですけれども
我々のグループも含めて
現在できるところから
いろんな宇宙エレベーターの技術を
確かめようという試みをしています
宇宙エレベーターを作るうえで
非常に重要なケーブルですけれども
これがどういう風に動いて
どういう力が掛かるか
これは設計に 非常に重要なんですけれども
これは コンピューター
シミュレーションによって
次第にどうなっているのか
というのがわかりつつあります
更に 荷物を運ぶクライマの部分ですけれども
これにつきましては
「日本宇宙エレベーター協会」というところが
ありまして そこが毎年開催している
これを通じて
どういう構造にすればいいか
どういう制御をすればいいか
そういったことを試しています
こちらの方が その宇宙エレベーター競技会の
動画ですけれども
(男性１：昇降開始します)
これは我々の静岡大学の
クライマの昇降する様子です
どんな形で昇っていくかというのが
わかるかと思いますけれども
(男性２：おお いいんじゃない
いいんじゃない いいんじゃない)
(男性２：止まった)
こういう競技会を通じて
次第に設計の方向というのが
わかりつつあります
また こういう競技会を実際に見られると
「宇宙エレベーターって
こんな形で昇って行くんだなぁ」
というのが想像できるかと思います
更に うちの静岡大学で開発して
去年 H-Ⅱ ロケットで
打ち上げられた
「はごろも」という衛星も
その技術を確かめる一環のものです
「はごろも」というのは
これは 天女が
羽衣によって天まで昇っていく
といういわゆる羽衣伝説ですね
これに因んで付けられた名前になります
羽衣伝説は 静岡の人たちには
馴染みが深いかと思いますけれども
この衛星は 何をしようか
としているかというと
先ほど宇宙エレベーターを作るとき
軌道上でケーブルを伸ばさなきゃいけない
ということを言ったかと思いますけれども
その軌道上でケーブルを伸ばすというのを
大学でも作れるぐらいのこれぐらいの
10センチ 20センチぐらいの大きさの
小さな衛星で確かめてみようという
そういう試みです
この衛星は現在 軌道周回中で
その本実験に向けて
通信とか そういったものを調整を
現在やってる最中です
更には この後の衛星も現在開発中です
次の衛星というのは もうちょっと大きな衛星
50センチぐらいの大きな衛星で
更に長いテザーを伸ばして
今度は そのテザーに沿って
クライマがどういう風に
軌道上で動くかという
これを確かめようという衛星です
これは多分数年後には
打ち上げられるかもしれません
こんな形で 宇宙エレベーターの
研究開発というのは
次第に広がりを見せつつあります
宇宙エレベーターというと
アニメとかSFでよく昔から
描かれてきたわけですけれども
私もその影響を受けて宇宙エレベーターに
対する憧れを持ったものです
しかしながら 宇宙エレベーターは
そういうSFとかアニメの中では
数百年後の技術として描かれていました
実際ですね 数十年前までは
誰もがそういう風に
思っていたわけですけれども
私自身も研究の道に入った当初というのは
宇宙エレベーターへの憧れはあっても
研究としては なかなかこう難しいなぁ
という
現実味がないなぁ
という風に思っていました
しかしながら
宇宙の新しい輸送システム
というのに関心があったんで
今 はやぶさで有名になった
「イオンエンジン」とか
それから 「宇宙テザー」という
こういう新しいシステムの研究を
ずっとやってきたわけですけれども
「宇宙テザー」というのは宇宙船同士を結ぶ
「紐」のことです
このテザー自身でもロケットを使わないで
輸送できるんですけれども
実は宇宙エレベーターのケーブル
これがまさにこのテザーなんですね
テザーの部分ということになります
宇宙エレベーターの研究を
今 私はやってますけれども
その上では 今までずっと続けてきた
このテザーの研究の
知識と経験というのが
非常に役立っています
研究を始めた当時は
意識していなかったんですけれども
当時 面白そうだなと
思って始めた研究というのが
非常に憧れていた宇宙エレベーターという
そういう研究に通じてくる
これはある意味ちょっと
運命的なものを感じています
皆さんも 今何気なく
取り組んでいることとか
それから勉強していることが
将来もっと大きなものの実現に
つながってくるということが
あるかもしれませんね
宇宙エレベーターですけれども
もう不可能な技術では
ないんですけれども
もちろんその克服すべき
いろんな課題が沢山あります
更には 宇宙エレベーターは 国際協力が
必要な非常に大きな巨大な事業です
それを完成させるためには
技術面だけではなく
法律とか経済とか政治とか
いろんなものが関わってくるので
それらを解決できる人が必要となってきます
宇宙エレベーターの研究をしている
我々は現在 その夢の実現に向けて
その基礎を築いていくべく
いろんな研究をしているんですけれども
恐らく 私も含めて
今 中高年の人たちが
宇宙エレベーターの
実現を見ることはないかと思います
しかしながら 若い人たちですね
若い人たちが 宇宙エレベーターの完成を見る
そういった完成に立ち会える
可能性は十分あります
しかも その宇宙エレベーターを
実現できるかどうかというのは
そういう若い人たちの
これからの広い分野での
活躍にかかってきているわけです
現在はですね なかなか夢を追いかける
というのが難しい時代ですけれども
人類の発展というのは
かつての ―
人たちが描いてきた
夢を実現するということによって
発展を遂げてきました
今ですね 我々は
特定の人だけではなくて誰でも
宇宙に自由に行き来できる
そういう可能性のある時代にいます
じゃあ そういう宇宙エレベーターが
できたら どんな世界になるのかな
というのを少し覗いてみましょう
どうですか？
こんな世界が来たらと思うと
わくわくしませんか
是非 こういう宇宙エレベーターのような
夢の技術 これに関心を持って
今はまだ サイエンスフィクション（SF）
かもしれないですけれども
それをサイエンスファクト（SF）にしていく
そういう気概を持った人たちが 我々に続いて
若い人たち どんどん育ってほしいと思います
そういうことを願っています
（拍手）